Yes. No. No. I I mean the billionaires.
>> dude. You can hear the saliva.
You dude. >> I I mean the billionaires.
Oh my god.
>> What the is What in the I told you, dude. I almost want
to puke listening to that. Holy [__]
But Pokemon did a video. She was She was talking about getting
an engagement ring. Okay. She got engaged and it's her. She's
engaged to her. She bought an engagement for herself. For herself.
She bought an engagement ring for herself. Oh my god.
Oh my god. Ring she bought herself. A lot of you were saying,
"Girl, just go get So, we'll just play the video. Give me a second.
I'm going to use the bathroom while this plays while you guys
get the context." Okay. I've already got the context. Load up.
Going to be a long >> An engagement ring for myself. Okay.
But you guys told me to. In the comments my last video, you guys
kept talking about a ring. A lot of you were saying, "Girl, just
go get one for yourself."
So, that's what I did. A ring at Vulyrie that I just fell in
love with. It felt like way too much to get for myself. But then
the more I thought about it, I was like, I hope someday I actually
get engaged. The person that you are engaged to the most in your
entire lifetime is your damn self. So why shouldn't I get this
ring for my damn self? So this is me proposing to myself. Damn.
Look at the gorgeous diamonds. Even the packaging is beautiful.
The way that it contrasts. You know when is so pretty you want
to eat it. Is that just me? Like it's so delectable.
Will I be with me for the rest of my life? Well, yes. I have
no choice. But yes, I'm gonna have the opportunity to gift my
husband the sickest engagement ring for men that there ever was.
And I cannot wait. You guys know how much I love and just that
>> Reban Ruben donated $3. Shout out to Shelbo for his
engagement.
>> Not Shelbo's engagement technically, but congrats Shelbo.
I'm sure you can pretend. Okay. Um, dude, the funny thing about
this Okay, so you guys have caught up on the context at this
point. The funny thing about this to me,
this is just Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. Exactly. Chinese agent.
I don't even know like if I describe as a bit She's just rage
baiting. She like she likes the fact that incelss get mad about
anything she does, so she just dreams up new ways of with like
random like internet incelss.
I I'm sorry.
Like I just feel like she's just trying to [__] with
people. That's it. And everybody falls for it and there's a whole
like media cycle around it and she just like cackles
collects collects money from donations. Okay.
Doesn't mean it's not still
I I'm sorry. She's like a rich person who's buying luxury stuff.
What is What is the difference between this and
I don't know like a $8,000 TV that you never watch as like a
rich person who lives in like multiple mansions.
What What's the difference? Yeah. Watch. What's the difference
between any of these things?
>> Saying it's an engagement ring.
>> Okay. So, just saying it's an engagement ring. So, you
the fact that she made a video about it
>> is the thing that's bad.
I I literally I just can't imagine caring like that much. It's
like, oh, it's a rich person. It's a rich person who bought themselves
something expensive for no reason. And then she made everybody
mad about it. Also, what's the difference between an engagement
ring and just a ring? Is this real or a joke? It's a joke. Is
it just the words you use?
What about the sanctity of marriage
yourself? Not really, actually. That's a joke in a video game.
That's a meme. That's a meme. That's a meme.
>> Actually, hold on real quick. I That's a joke. That's
a joke. That's a joke. But I am going to end the Twitch stream.
We're going to go over to kick.com/jk. See you guys over there
in a little bit. Bye. Unrelated though. Bye.
>> I
listen. I said it was a joke. I said it was a joke. It It was
a joke, but I don't want to [__] around with it.
Okay. Very scary stuff. Very scary. Very scary
Whoops. Yeah, VOD's gone. VOD be gone. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Not good. Not good. Not good. Let me
let me switch over off of multireaming. What a what a weird time
to end the stream. I kind of wanted to do the Pokemon stuff over
on Twitch, too, but unlucky. Okay, unlucky.
Sorry. The sanctity of marriage, bro. What sanctity of marriage?
Where? She's not getting married. It's an engagement ring. I
know Teto made a video on it. That's why I'm That's why I'm going
to watch or that's what I'm going to watch.
I'm watching all this stuff. I got so many recommendations for
this. I had no idea why people were complaining about Pokemon
again and I realized that she's just rage baiting. She's making
money off of people.
>> Yeah, I know. I do keep deleting the Twitch VODs, unfortunately.
But
we'll watch the Techone response. There's a bunch of responses.
There's a bunch of stuff going on here. Okay, it's good. It's
all good. Okay, so there's the video. I think we're Dude, this
music is so loud. I have it turned down so much. I need like
normalization. I need like equalization for I actually have an
extension that does EQ. Hold on.
>> Let me
hold on. I need to I need to like EQ this tab because I swear
like some of the music on this playlist.
Oh, I can't EQ the tab. Okay, well, I don't care anymore. sit
and play again cuz some of the music is so loud and then some
of it's so like now you guys can't even hear this music. It's
like basically not coming through. Oh well. Oh no, that's coming
through. All right, let's watch the end here and then we're going
to go over to the techone video. We might do another video on
it. Okay, there's a Tactical Templar video on this as well, I
believe. All right, very very exciting. Very interesting stuff.
>> I can't wait. You guys know how much I love gift giving
and just that idea makes me so happy. the idea of giving the
gift to her husband or giving the ring to her husband, gifting
the engagement ring to her husband? Uh, does she mean gifting
it to her husband so that husband can give it back to her? Cuz
that ring might not look that great on a guy. I don't know if
that's
She even sounds so sarcastic.
I don't listen, I have no idea what she's really doing here.
Like if if she was just buying a ring for herself and she decided
to frame it this way. But she's clearly rage baiting.
Like obviously rage baiting just like Dingolingus is obviously
rage baiting here. I just trying to I choose to believe it's
not rage bait. Well, if you wanted to hate women, if that was
your primary goal being online was just to go online and be like
all these stupid
then I understand that personally is not my goal. But hey, if
it's your goal, I have nothing. You know, I'm not going to stand
in the way of that. You go, you go off. You do you. All right.
I appreciate
Go hard, buddy. >> Okay. All right. We
>> I don't know if I want to do Teone and Tactical Templar.
I might want to do
I would love to hear a Tactical Templar drool over something
today. Okay, that's like the height of my day is just listening
to Tact Tactical Templar drool onto his keyboard. Let's check
it out. Let's watch. Let's give it a look. Only a 13-minute video,
guys. Only a 13-minute video.
Brothers, Pokemon is just so sad. What I have to show you today
is the ultimate cope. And and this is what women like Pokemon
do. They play these games with tradition
and you know marriage and kids and they play these goofy games
and the >> Oh, he's got a new He's got a new avatar. Let's
go. >> And we're going to see this where
>> Dude, I turned I turned the uh >> puts a video
out online and she goes, "Guys, I don't understand how this is.
>> I got an engagement ring.
>> I bought it for myself.
Oh my god.
This is something that has to be seen to be believed. This is
This is so unbelievably pathetic.
I don't The sanctity of marriage point is so stupid to me. She's
not getting married. Did you know that in the Bible they don't
actually mention engagement rings and this is a with the sanctity
of marriage whatsoever? You idiot.
That's not an really important part of of the Bible. Holy [__]
>> I I just I have to show it to you. I
I cannot pass this by. Uh ladies and gentlemen, this is one of
my guilty pleasures. The fact that Pokemon
is everything that I argue against.
>> Bro, how how quickly did he find this? 91 likes. Wait,
did he scroll down? He scrolled down a little bit, right? >> This
is Hold on. >> My guilty pleasures. >> 33 minutes.
So within 30 minutes he's live. He's talking about Pokemon. You'd
love to see it. He like saw it WAS LIKE THIS STUPID [__]
AND HE WENT LIVE like immediately or he made a video. I'm not
sure which. >> The fact that Pokemon
is everything that I argue against
one of these. >> I I personally would pick like somebody
who's not
I how would I how do I put this? I personally would pick like
a different bow. Not somebody who like does what does she do
like 10 hours of streams a week and posts Instagram reels. Is
that really it's she's everything you argue against. She doesn't
even do bro. She's like not even she's not even like like the
traditional online horror archetype that these people will go
after. The worst thing she does is is like maybe thirst post
to her IG or Twitter once in a while. It's not even close. >> Evacuous
vapid bimbos
that will go out and say, "Eat the rich guys. We hate the rich.
And meanwhile, the guy with her is like, "Wait, aren't you rich?"
>> Yes. No. No. I I mean the billionaires, >> dude.
You can hear the saliva.
You dude
I mean the billionaires.
Oh my god. What the is What in the I told you, dude. I almost
want to puke listening to that. Holy [__] That was
so gross.
That was so gross. Hold on. So gross, dude.
Why? Why does that exist though? What the dude?
This is This person is like everything I say is wrong in the
world. Okay, this is I don't whatever that sound is. Holy I'm
like actually I'm bordering on gagging listening to it. It's
like,
>> I can't even do the fake gag sound. Cuz when I do the
fake gag sound, I think about the sound he just made and then
in my mind, I actually feel like gagging. It's I >> Oh,
man. Jesus. >> This stupid virtue signaling doesn't realize
the chaos that she's courting.
>> What virtue is she signaling here? What the virtue of
being rich?
What? What virtue is she sign? There isn't a virtue she's signaling
here. What? Like nothing this guy says makes any sense. It doesn't
make any sense. She's not signaling a virtue. >> All in
favor of her
radical empathy and desire to be perceived in a positive.
>> Oh, so he's just taking Asmin Gold talking points. Asmin
Gold like memes
empathy. Radical empathy. Uh this is a thing. Runous empathy
is absolutely a thing. How does it where is she? Who is she being
empathetic to? What is happening? Where's the Where's the empathy?
She doesn't talk about politics. Is she doing a ton of political
streams?
[__] is she doing? You're just you're you're basically
fighting against some like leftist online influencers without
actually referencing them without actually doing anything. You're
like you're fighting ghosts. You're fighting demons. >> Like
despite doing >> well, Asmin Gold uses it correctly. Asmin
Gold's not a [__] This guy's just saying things Asminold
says and hoping that he eventually picks up in the algorithm.
nothing to earn it. But anyway,
all of you were saying, "Girl, just go get one for yourself."
So that's what I did. The person that you are engaged to the
most in your entire life is your damn self. So why shouldn't
I get this ring? Pokemon bought herself an engagement ring. And
I understand from her perspective, she thinks this is a dunk
on people like me. But this is one of the most embarrassing and
humiliating things that I've seen in quite some time. The reality
is that, and let me just break it down. No one in Pokemon's life
is going to be as honest as I am. Isn't that ironic? Somebody
that she would deem as a hater.
Wow. This feels like a dunk on me. I bro other people just being
happy. Although I hold on listen that might be there's a world
where that's not the most thing he's ever said. Okay, hold on.
There's a world where that's not the most thing he's ever said
cuz I do feel like Pokemon probably did this explicitly for him
to like soy the [__] out for over not like him directly
but Techone and a bunch of other people. Right. Wait until he
sees As I guarantee Asmin's going to look at this and he's going to
go, "Oh, this is rage bait. this is silly. I don't care. And
move on, right? He'll have the correct response and then they'll
all feel
But listen, far be it for me to tell you what this guy's going
to say, to tell you like anything. Listen, we got to let him
cook. Okay, let him cook. >> And let me just break it down.
No one in
>> Pokemon's life is going to be as honest as I am. Isn't
that ironic? Somebody that she would deem as a hater
is going to demonstrate more love to her than anyone in her chat
and anyone in her
because
I somehow don't think that's true. But you know, I'll let him
I'll let him cook more. Okay, he's going to show her more love
than anyone in her chat. Dude, he can't even rage and want to
kill all women, which is his position.
Okay. He can't even rage out without sing. I'm going to I'm going
to love you more than anyone else in your life. I'm I'm going
to say the things that you need to hear. I'm I'm going to love
you more than anyone else in your
>> The truth, while it is difficult, the truth is love.
The truth is giving you the important information to make an
informed decision that is best for you.
>> The only one who will tell you that you're a stupid
vapid vacuous
That's what real love is. Real love is just real love is telling
you that you're a vacuous vapid to you and filling your head
with noise
and allowing you to make bad decisions. That is not love. So
without further ado,
let's play this and then I'm going to give you my opinion on
it.
This
self-engagement
which is the biggest load of horseshit I've ever heard. bought
an engagement ring for myself. Okay, but you guys told me to.
In the comments my last video, you guys kept talking about a
ring. A lot of you were saying, "Girl, just go get one for yourself."
So, that's what I did. A ring at Bulry that I just fell in love
with. It felt like way too much to get for myself. But then the
more I thought about it, I was like, I hope someday I actually
get engaged. The person that you are engaged to the most in your
entire lifetime is your damn self.
I mean, the most narcissist dude, I am hearing it now. It feels
like she literally went to a writer's room and was like, "What's
some crazy we could say that's going to rile up all these losers
online." I swear to God. I swear to God. I think she actually
did that. You'll never be able to prove it. It's like one of
those things. It's like a conspiracy theory. Okay, this is my
Candace Owens moment. I'll say I'll never be able to prove it.
But I believe she like secretly when she's just chilling at night,
she's like, "Wonder how I could make Techone mad. I wonder how
I could just like pick techone off and make this guy soy the
[__] out again. I think she's actually doing that.
Okay. Unironically, this guy's like a right-wing culture slop
early LLM.
Uh yeah, I think we called these like Marov chains before, right?
He knows all of the words and phrases. Yeah, he knows them all.
He doesn't know how to use them. It's kind of like Andrew Wilson.
Okay. We're a landlocked country living in the uniquely the the
unique in the world. Okay. Unique in the world for the continent.
It's not landlocked. It's the least landlocked country. It has
access to both oceans with multiple warm water ports. It's the
least landlocked country.
Sorry, just back to that's that's what Tactical Templar is doing
here. Okay.
Empathy. This woman bought a ring. She has empathy.
>> The most vapid, the most selfish.
And you know what? I don't think this is a bit I don't I don't
think she's playing it up or or playing a character because if
so, this is one of the longest roles she's ever played. She is
I'll be honest, the fact that he actually actually entertained
the idea that it might be a bit shocks me. Shocks me deeply.
Okay. The fact that he actually entertains the idea that she
might not or she might be playing it a part. She might be doing
a bit. That's crazy. I didn't think he'd even consider >> a
narcissistic and she has been for a very long time.
This is a woman that you want to avoid being around and you want
to avoid being like
Pokemon
is not a role model or a woman for emulation.
I would make a joke that she's a woman for emulation, but people
would take it literally and say, "Oh, you're death threating
her." No, but you should burn away all of the feminist gobbledygook,
all of the completely and totally obliterate
that from your life.
What she is saying here is poison.
>> Sweet
sounding poison. And if you want to go for a career and you want
to put that first, you are going to end up as an empty egg carton
like this woman. And by the way, she's getting older. Her looks
are going to start to go. She's not going to be able to have
kids. She's not going to be able to provide for her husband.
And she's too much of an egotist to even give her husband kids
because as she Okay, hold on. Hold on. I think he was going to
say provide her husband with kids or something cuz
>> her looks are going to start to go. She's not going
to be able to have kids. She's not going to be able to provide
for her husband and she's too
>> provide for her husband. I think she he was saying she's
not going to be able to provide. Okay, that's the one where you're
totally wrong. Yeah, I know about the egg cart. Dude, I have
a hard time I have a hard time reacting to the egg carton comments
to be honest with you. They're just so obvious. I also realistically
there is a thing where if you're a rich woman who's getting paid
for your looks and all you have to do is maintain your looks,
that's very doable into a late age if you just don't like [__]
it up,
right? She's obviously started skincare like incredibly early.
I'm I'm just saying she's probably going to look good for a long
time. >> Are you an egotist to even >> give her husband?
>> But even if she didn't even if she wasn't that way.
>> I just don't
get whatever because as she says, everything is about her. Everything
is about herself. This is the type of woman that you want to
avoid at all cost. She is a massive massive red flag and not
just because she's wearing a red dress, which you know, she is
literally wearing a red flag.
Women like this. >> Great point. I dude, this breakdown
is changing my mind. Actually, I went into this thinking that
Pokemon is not a totally vacuous vapid who is self indulgent
and and the worst person on earth. And he's really convincing
me. Okay. She's literally wearing a red flag. I didn't see that.
>> Are the ones that fill other women, >> BUT SHE
HAS HORNS. SHE'S LIKE A DEVIL. She's like she's got horns. Oh
my god. >> Ted, you don't need a man. You love yourself,
woman. Love your curves. all of this
that destroys women and leaves them miserable.
Do not ever listen to a woman like this who goes on and buys
herself an engagement ring. And the reason why nobody wants to
put a ring on her finger, not really.
Nobody that she would love, admire, and respect is because
she's
difficult. And that's Oh,
>> based on what?
I mean, I would assume that she's like I don't know. I I would
assume there's probably she's not doesn't like relationships
because I've never seen her in one. But like why would he assume
that? Why why
would you assume she's difficult? I just don't get it. I Where
where's the evidence for that? >> Just insecure.
>> Like I
It's entirely possible. Hypothetically, it's entirely possible.
She's in a field with a bunch of narcissists. She doesn't like
those narcissists. She has a hard time dating like outside of
that. No. There is a man.
No. >> Oh, she talks about having high standards. Okay,
maybe >> she is not somebody's peace. She is a selfish,
delusional
hag. And the truth is,
>> okay, man. I don't want to make it seem like I'm just
going to say everything he says is wrong, but is she delusional?
Doesn't she have like legions of people who would marry her instantly?
Is it even a delusion?
Is Is her life not literally just all about herself? She just
gets to stream about herself. She gets to post Tik Toks about
herself. She's got all of this money. Like I It's not even a
delusion. She just gets to do whatever she wants.
That maybe that's the thing that makes him so upset is she's
like escape the loop.
Hey, dude. You guys get really mad over these key
I get that he's calling her a hag. He's I'll be real with you.
We all know what that is, right? He's been watching a lot of
Queen Vots, okay?
He's trying to analyze his enemy and
But I'm just telling you like people can be mad. She's just escaped
the loop. She doesn't have to work anymore. She's independently
wealthy. She doesn't have to do anything. She can do whatever
she wants. And she just like taunts people with it. Why' you
say legions though? Because from the only the only piece of data
I have is Shelbo. Okay,
that's it.
I just she she won. You don't have to get mad. Just be like,
"Yeah, I want to I want to win, too. I want to escape the loop.
She won though. You can't you can't be mad at Pokémon. She won.
She won. She doesn't need any of the things you're talking about
now. Maybe maybe she'd be happy with companionship. Who knows?
But she she won. Why are we What's the loop? The loop of having
to like work and and build a life in like some way that requires
planning over time, right? She doesn't have to plan anymore.
She literally can just she could opt out. She's out of the game.
She fell out whenever she wants. She's getting paid all her money.
She got all her money. She can go. and the truth show set you
free
that she
embodies
the cancerous
rotten output of feminism and modernity and what it does to women.
This woman has money but nobody respects her. Nobody values what
she has to say. She gets sh on all the time. She tries to do
a white label white label cookie product and she gets called
the cookie monster by me and other people. >> My bubble
doesn't like her so nobody respects her. Nobody likes her. She
gets called the cookie monster by me. People like me >> label
cookie b she gets sh on all the time. She tries to do a white
label white label cookie product and >> white label
monster by me and other
>> If you're a broke boy just say so. Dude, you
h
I I need to know what this guy looks like. I I feel like
I'll be real. I feel like fat is not what I'm feeling anymore.
Like I wonder if this guy's like quadripolgic or something and
just doesn't have good control of his diaphragm cuz he's actually
like drowning while he streams, while he talks. Like the whole
time he's just drowning in saliva. >> I don't know how
to explain that. >> I thought it was fat.
Tomorrow is my first Friday. Then I get Thanksgiving off and
have to work on actual Friday. Here's three bucks because of
capitalism.
>> Well, thank you very much, Ruben. Ruben, I appreciate
it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> By the way,
we hate the rich. >> Wait, does he Does she say that? I
don't I think Pokemon stays pretty far away from that, doesn't
she?
Why would she say you just add these things on to her? Woman
equals leftist equals I can do all the political attacks on her.
You're rich in money, but you're not rich in love, and you're
not rich in family. You're not rich in anything that actually
matters. >> She said, "Eat the rich recently." Well, that's
stupid. >> You're basically a brand as a human being. How
sad.
How pathetic.
And you coping this way.
I mean, this is just
this is just disgraceful. You coping with this, guys. I You said
to go get a ring. >> Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Hold on. Hold on. This
might be a fair point from him. Listen, I don't watch Pokemon
anywhere near as much as this guy does. Okay, so I should I should
be less egotistical and assume that he knows things Pokemon said
that I haven't. Okay, I do not meticulously follow or a log Pokemon.
This guy does. >> Pokemon shows herself yet again in controversy,
but this time for her eat the rich statement. >> Do you
think someday we'll have a revolution like that in America? Right.
It's getting there, right? >> We already have one. >> Another
one. The wealth disparity is getting bad. >> The wage gave.
I hate that. >> No wealth disparity. W
>> this guy. What a huge win.
>> This guy This guy's like a total NPC who's just used
to being on dates with like leftist women in LA and he's just
used to Yeah. Wealth gap. Yeah. Wage gap. Wage gap. Women don't
make enough, man. Yeah. Yeah. True. I >> wage gap is like
between men and women. Men and women, we love each other. >> That
starts. >> And we hate the rich. Anyways, >> aren't
you the rich? >> No. Like the ultra rich. The
>> Okay. No, you are the rich. You are the rich. Oh boy.
This is a This is a crack. This is not a good clip. Okay. This
is not a good clip. I I now feel silly. Okay. A little silly.
A little bit. I'll be real. I'll be real.
I lean towards this being a bit too, but I'm going to keep letting
>> the unnecessary to clarify. They're gonna clip that
and it's gonna make you look bad. >> No. Okay. She hates
the Oh boy. Do we Do we flip this to a Pokemon hate segment
>> I hate the unnecessarily rich. Like the needlessly rich.
Like the the unreasonably rich
>> I bought an engagement ring for myself for no reason.
Templar vindicated.
Uh yeah. You know what? Let's call it Templar Vindicated. Okay.
Templar is correct about everything. Listen, all he had to do
was look at this person and know that she was a woman and he
knew everything about her. Okay? I could never. This guy pondered
his orb. He was like, "Woman, uh, dumb leftist hypocrite
Dude, we're about to realize that Pokemon actually slept her
way up the streaming ladder the whole time. I have no idea.
Yeah. No, it's stupid. Okay. It's It's actually stupid. She's
very dumb for this. Very very dumb for this. She's just repeating
it properly. Not great. Well, she she looks really stupid complaining
about excess wealth and then doing this. Okay. I'm I'm just saying
you can't be doing a bit in both places.
What I I choose to believe in my head cannon, okay, that she
is like a ruthless capitalist who does this to like virtue signal
and just like goof on people like the sorry, this one would be
the virtue signal and and to like goof on people who believe
this in my head. Okay. In my head, let's continue on with Tactical
Templar. So, I went and I bought a ring and I said, "Well, it's
a little expensive,
but who better to buy something for than me?" You know, am I
>> Oh gosh, somebody throw a pie. It's just
>> The hatred is awesome.
>> Somebody throw a pie. >> You can't You can't deny
the visceral hatred he has for this person. Okay,
>> you can't like he has such visceral hatred. It's so
funny.
It's unreal. It really is. When you sit down and you think about
it, the behavior of these people,
the conceit.
They abandon tradition. And for what?
To glaze themselves.
To do a skit like this. Get the out of >> So why shouldn't
I get this ring? >> He abandoned tradition. >> So
this is me
proposing to myself. >> Damn. Look at the gorgeous diamonds.
Even the packaging is beautiful. The way that it contrasts, you
know, when is so pretty, you want to eat it. Is that just me?
Like, it's so delectable.
Will I be with me for the rest of my life? Well, yes. I have
no choice. But yes, I'm going to have the opportunity to gift
my husband the sickest engagement ring for
>> Oh, he's going to load up on this one. >> That
there ever was. And I cannot wait. You guys know how much I love
gift giving and just that idea makes me so
>> It's never going to happen.
It's never going to happen because the type of guy that would
have to >> Oh, I just realized he's he's he's
uh what do you call it? He's taking notes from Myin. Okay, that's
that's Myin's position, right? That women can't be happy with
somebody who makes less money than them, that has less wealth
than them. they can only be happy with somebody like like uh
richer or whatever. And I think that's where he's going to go.
Well, she'll never be satisfied with any man. So, she'll never
get married. She can't be happy. She can't be happy. She'll never
settle for somebody who makes less than her and and treats her
right. Okay. Actually, that would be the best if he inserted
himself. There are guys out there who would treat her right,
who would be like dedicated to her, but she'll never be able
to see them. She'll never see them. >> Settle for you.
And by the way, you are a huge settlement because you are never
going to be a man's piece. The type of guys that would um that
would marry you
are not the type of guys that you would be interested in. They're
not the type of guys that you would love, admire, and respect.
They're not masculine men. They're men that basically are with
you for your fame and for your money
because uh they want your clout.
But by the way, like your looks and like the eggs that are drying
up like it's a [__] Denny's cooktop. This guy, this
guy's going off. This guy's on one >> has a time limit.
I don't say this to be mean. I say it because it's the truth.
>> I don't say it to hurt Pokemon. I say it to try to help
other women.
Don't be like this. Don't act like this.
You think that in 20, 30 years when she still has no husband,
she's got no kids. You think when she's still buying stuff for
herself, crying herself to sleep, drinking comically large glasses
of wine, and having a bunch of cats, you think that she's really
in her private moments going to be like this, going to be like,
"Ha, I made all the right choices." No, of course not.
No, this is a cope and it's one that women do because they don't
want to admit that they made a mistake and they don't want to
take accountability.
>> This guy goes into Elmer Fud in those high saliva moments,
>> even amongst themselves. So, she'll put out this thing
to own the haters.
I'm going to own the haters by engaging myself. I mean, okay.
>> I think he's actually got the right read on that. This
is maybe the best Templar video I've seen. I think she did do
this explicitly just to with people like him. I think that's
actually correct.
>> I mean, this is embarrassing.
And by the way, you're a vain. You're you're somebody that Oh,
I don't like drama, guys. You By the way, you deleted that post,
Pokemon. you deleted that post because you're a stupid and you
ran your mouth about trying to destroy somebody's life uh couple
weeks ago and the guy moved on and then you wanted to ruin his
life because it was funny to you. Um, no, you're going to die
alone and your family is most likely going to go on and have
families of their own. And you know, you're going to be you're
going to be that one example of the miserable,
wine aunt
that everyone hates but has to put up with.
>> That's that's your future. I'm looking into my crystal
ball. No, it's just what it is. Doesn't require crystal ball.
doesn't require clairvoyance. It just is looking at the patterns
of behavior. >> Um, like man, how do I put this? I feel
like even if that were all true, let's say that all comes to
pass. I don't think there's like actual analysis go. This is
just a broken clock moment, right? All this guy does is is say
the exact same Myron Gaines, Andrew Tate,
Molly meme script all all the time. He just repeats it over and
over and over again, right? It's like even if that were to all
come to pass, you're not doing it based on anything going on
in her life.
Like all indications are she can do whatever she wants like forever.
You're you're worried about it coming to an end. I don't know
if it will come to an
Maybe maybe there's some concern that she isn't seeking deeper
meaning. But to be honest, if that's the problem is that Pokémon's
not seeking deeper meaning in life. She's not seeking like deep
meaningful relationships. I think that's probably a problem with
becoming famous, becoming like a famous streamer.
She's got so much money, she's got so much um clout that she
probably does have a hard time finding meaning meaningful relationships.
But then where are you going to call her a hypocrite? You're
doing the same thing. You're you're seeking this path yourself.
That might be that could be listen that could all be true. But
if it is that she will never see or she can't seek like meaningful
relationships, I guarantee you way more than her personal ego.
It's the fact that she's a streamer. It's my opinion. Like a
famous a super famous streamer, super rich. Anyway, you are going
to be miserable and alone. And the type of guy that you may eventually
marry you maybe
is going to be a guy that you settle for
let's just face it, the type of guys that you would think on
are on your level as narcissistic as you are, are not going to
be interested in you. They don't want you.
You're stupid.
You're an embarrassment.
You're
>> Why I like I I could almost understand him being really
mad at like Only Fans people, but she doesn't do any kind of
that that kind of content at all. Like she she at most posts
like some outfits
>> Uh you bend over an awful lot for
what, like 13, 14, 15year-old? >> How would you know that?
Wait, how does he know that? Wait, what is he watching that he
is aware of this this phenomenon happening? You bend over a lot
for 13, 14, 15y old guys. That's what you do. >> Kids in
your Twitch stream, you're [__] pathetic.
>> Like, okay, >> cope as much as you want, but everyone
sees through it.
And you know, whether it's
>> one year, 5 years, 10 years, you're going to be crying
yourself to sleep because you decided that the feminist rap was
more important. You decided yourself was more important than
a family.
God, your parents must be ashamed of you. I know I would be.
And
>> uh her parents also got to escape the loop. They no
longer have to work. I I I'm sorry.
[__] man. People don't understand like how much this
kind of like wealth changes the game entirely. It's >> Anyway,
uh that'll do it, ladies and gentlemen. Thanks for watching.
>> That's it. See you next time. >> That's it. >> First
Templars family. Dude, the I maybe that's where it all comes
from. Is this just jealousy that she could have everything he
wants in the world and she denies it, right? That's like where
the jealousy comes from.
Have we seen this? I don't know anything about the Misfit Patriot
guy. I We could take a look at it. Somebody sent it to me. Or
wait, no, no, no. I think uh Shimu tweeted it. I I don't know
anything about him. He's a right-wing like arguer. I know he
just debated lonerbox on UK immigration policy or something.
Okay, sure. That was a banger. Grock is falsely accusing me of
being a Any lawyers out there want to take on a case. Proonoto.
>> I have a question for my lawyer friends.
>> this is the guy who married um the the right-wing comedian
woman, right? What is her name? He like got engaged to her recently.
Can I and should I sue Elon Musk for Grock calling me a um because
that happened and people are throwing it in my comment section
and like like you know using it. >> Wait, did he Wait,
did this actually happen though? Did he actually get charged
with this >> to try to smear me? Usually I don't really
care about you know the smears. People are like, "Oh, here's
you on a gay dating app or something." But this came from Elon
Musk's
AI
and I don't I don't I don't think it should do that. >> Why
isn't he like just say this is a fake? First thing you should
do Yeah. First thing you should do is just say no, no, it's not
real. It's fake.
>> Obviously, you can just verify that it's false by looking
up my name, case number that it's providing. Um, it's just patently
false, but it's very convincing to some people. Bro, how did
it re real talk, how did it just hallucinate this guy's charges,
his his child charges? That seems like an actual problem. >> Here's
somebody in my comment section who's saying, "Well, why does
AI say it's true?" Well, that's what I'm asking the lawyers,
right? That's why I'm making this post, just in case any of them
want to.
>> This is This is like embarrassing, but actually, this
is a real problem. This is like a real actual problem.
Who's feeding Grock this information? >> Me up. Why does
AI say it's true? Yeah, I don't know. Maybe it's because a bunch
of
crazy people are lying about me on the internet and Grock is
just aggregating that information. But I don't think artificial
intelligence should do that. I don't think it should go well
but said it's true, so it's true.
Now, according to Grock,
I was arrested for child. Didn't happen. Dude. Uh, there's no
way he can stop this from getting clipped. Okay. Right. >> Hold
on.
>> Oh, come on. >> I was arrested for child
>> I was arrested for child.
>> Like, it's just Why would you? Unfortunately, you got
that there. Now, that's like it exists.
I God damn it. >> That's dude. Uh, but if somebody did
believe that,
>> then they'd probably rightfully want to uh, well, murder
me and and I don't want that to happen at all.
>> I've called for the death of a lot of, and this is very
scary to me. >> And Elon Musk might think this is funny.
Um, because 4 days ago, he said Grock was unfortunately manipulated
by adversarial prompting into saying absurdly
positive things about me. For the record, I am a fat.
Um, I think it's a little different when it's saying
I'm a And here's Elon Musk using Grock to ask the prompt, does
he have an arrest record in reference to a different story. Meaning
that Elon Musk thinks if you ask Grock whether or not somebody
has an arrest record, whatever Grock tells you is the truth.
>> So again, any lawyers out there want to help me out
with this? I
man I I just asked Grock and it still says sorry I think they
fixed it but damn. Uh I just asked Grock and it still says it's
true. I'd like to think this guy's trolling. He just made him
like actually search am I a and it like responds yes. Yes you
are. Dude that's that is crazy. You want to play the you want
to play the victim constantly.
I don't know. It's I'm sorry. It's very funny. It also kind of
sucks legitimately. Even though this guy is a total re that does
kind of suck.
Grock Grock is Grock has deemed this guy hopefully this is not
a glimpse into the future. Okay, Grock is actually doing precog
work now and it it knows about the charges but it assigns them
a date. All right, whenever it references things that are going
to happen in the future, it actually they just like patched it
out really badly. Just assigns the year back like three or four
years.
Unlucky, man. Unlucky.
Okay, we finished with the with the Templar video. We'll we'll
give the TechOne video a quick look for Oh, we look at the tweet
first. So, Techone quote tweeted O, "Holy, this is the most pathetic
thing I've ever seen in my entire life. Good lord."
Okay. All right.
I'll remind you, Te's entire career is based on promoting
Lollcon gambling to miners to to anybody who will watch. Okay,
that's Tee's entire career is taking advertising sponsors for
gotacha games that almost exclusively fe feature like small like
young children, drawn depictions of young children being
okay, I'm sorry, that is his career and he's going to go, "This
is the most pathetic thing I've ever seen in my entire life."
No, Teone, your career is the most pathetic thing you've ever
seen in your entire life by a lot. By like not even a little
bit. You advertise like legal gambling for kids that use like
all of these like these like scamp scantly dressed scantily clad
scantily clad lollycon characters. Okay, [__] you.
You Tee don't don't try to say Pokey's pathetic when your entire
career was built on being a pathetic [__] loser.
Okay, and I'm I'm not even somebody who talks Tech's turn. I
think it's like weird and hypocritical to go and [__]
when other people are still degenerates. But like if he if he
thinks he's going to find religion and build a family and turn
his life around and that's going to make him happy all like all
the blessing in the world to him. Okay, good luck. But doing
this like coming around and and looking down on people, not trying
to help just just like casting judgment on people. Weird. Gross.
Shouldn't do it.
But anyway, let's check out the techone video on Pokemon.
Pokemon.
I I like saying Pokemon, though. Okay, I know it's Pokemon, but
we're going to say Pokemon. Look, WestJet video. The Pokemon
situation is embarrassing.
Weird stuff. Okay. All right. We're going to watch this. Give
me two seconds. I'll be right back. I just got to go get some
water. >> Good morning, boys. Cheers. Hope you're all doing
well. Miss you guys, but we'll see you soon. More info on that
later. And yesterday was uh the best day of my life. And I never
thought things would be this good again. But sometimes when God
puts these horrific, terrible, miserable challenges in your way,
life will seem insurmountable. Things will seem unattainable.
But when you push through these challenges, there really is paradise
on the other side. And boys, we are in fact in paradise right
now. Things are great, things are going great, and I never thought
things would go this good for me ever again. I feel human. I
feel happy. And I just feel very positive about everything going
on in my life. And I can honestly say >> I can only assume
that uh that his ex-girlfriend was like killed by the same woman
who killed Luna Zerutska. Okay. I can only assume that something
terrible happened to Pinky Shoe at this point or his ex-wife.
One of those two people, right? Realistically, most likely I
think probably one of his cases got dropped or something. I'm
guessing one of his cases got dropped. one of the things that
was going to go bad or or might go bad for him probably dropped
or something terrible happened to those people cuz he is not
somebody who who relies on positive good things happening to
like him. He's going to take like bad things happening to other
people and they're going to make him feel good. So, I'm that's
my guess. Maybe we could look at it in just a little bit. >> Even
though this break is soon coming to an end, it was a great decision
on my part uh to get away from everything and really focus on
the fundamentals of life and getting back to center.
Now, time to do my favorite thing about on the internet. And
today's is none other than Pokemon.
YEAH, MAN. THIS CHICK is so dumb. It's insane. Um, we got so
much to talk about. What it means, what she did, and how this
affects the youth of our society in the years to come. Well,
let's talk about all this. Pokemon, everyone's favorite Yas girl
boss has been on a roll lately about even just >> uh in
the background. We're watching this. Okay. Apparently, Pokemon
being a vapid vacuous has dire drastic implications for society,
guys.
>> She put out a tweet called, "Man, I'm so tired of the
>> This is all because she got engaged. She didn't actually
get engaged. She got quote unquote engaged to herself." Okay,
it's like a little meme post pro probably just actually poke
poking at uh incelss, right? Literally just I think people are
gonna get really mad about that. Guys are infinite content cows
for her. Well, there's a symbiotic relationship going on here
where everybody is a content cow. It's like a a cycle. Okay,
it's an oraoros.
All right, of content >> the drama. I miss when Twitch
stream
gaming. Okay, first of all, if you want Twitch to be about gaming,
then pull up a video game and play it. It's not hard. Second
of all, that's very rich coming from the woman who was calling
people the based, by the way. As well as farming goers for engagement
for the past, I don't know, 8 years. Pokemon Man, let's just
be real. If you didn't have a huge ass, you wouldn't have a career.
And I'm just going to be the guy to say it. We're all thinking
it. And that's the goddamn >> Okay, that's entirely possible.
Was she showing her huge ass a lot?
I I
don't know. I've never seen Listen, I have not watched a lot
of Pokemon content. But is she like bending over showing this
huge ass all the time? Yeah, I don't I don't know what this is
in reference to.
I I actually don't get it. These people are just disconnected
from reality. Well, I say that. Hold on. Hold on. I say that.
All right. I did find out that she she had that really stupid
comment about eating the rich. All right. So, maybe Te's correct
here. And I just I haven't looked into Pokémon enough to know
that she has a huge ass >> truth. Anyways,
she goes
yesterday
and she does the unthinkable. I didn't
women in the United States could get any more pretentious, but
holy, here we are in 2025.
Um, I got so much to talk about. This is insane. So, she posts
a video
where, and I not, ladies and gentlemen, if you haven't seen this,
my god, I recommend you avoid it to avoid getting the cancer
from merely watching this, where she goes and she buys an engagement
ring for
as some like, "Yes, girl, boss. You go girl." And all the little
Pokemon simps in her comments like, "Oh my god, yes,
you don't need no man." Yes. Uh, very uh homophobic by the way,
assuming only a man can get a woman a ring. What? What? What's
going on here, guys? Maybe I'm not the only bigot. So, if she
buys
>> dude. Engagement ring for
>> Bro, these people
I don't get it. I don't I need to stop watching Techone. I actually
shouldn't have engaged with this topic. I just immediately become
like so blackpilled. It's like there's so many viewers for this.
So many people who are like so lost. They're just like, "Oh yeah,
techone. This is awesome." Yeah, we're not the only bigots. Look,
they didn't even consider that a she could be in a relationship.
Why does it have to be a >> for herself? And says the quote
of
>> I was always waiting for a man to get me one of these.
But you know,
if there's one thing I'm going to be married to the longest,
it's myself. So, I bought myself an engagement ring.
Oh, Jesus. I want a cute. It was ridiculous. Uh yeah, Pokemon
bought a engagement ring for herself as some like super pro-woman.
Look at how empowered I am. I don't need no man. My god.
Holy.
We can we just stop with all this.
Men are evil, white men are terrible. I mean, good [__]
>> Ah, yes. Pokemon has I I forgot about the part where
Pokemon said, "Listen,
I would marry somebody, but the only people who have ever proposed
to me are white guys, and I can't do that." Okay, >> this
is one African queen they will not colonize. All right, that's
a quote. That's a direct quote for Pokémon. Even I was brainwashed
by this [__] Like at least what five, six years ago.
I used to be in a relationship
where my partner didn't cook, didn't clean, didn't pay for any
bills. Dude, I am the conflict resolution god.
>> He's a he's a god at it. Okay. He had all these problems,
dealt with them for years, didn't do anything to to I guess clean
it up at all. I mean, >> and we did not have sex at all.
None.
Isn't that because you I thought his whole cope this whole time
was that he couldn't have
>> Wasn't that his thing? Is he just rewriting history
at this point? I thought he couldn't. Isn't that the whole thing?
He can't he literally can't [__] vagina because of
some trauma in his past because he was raped as a kid by a woman.
Tequila sunset. I don't say that to like judge him for it. Okay.
He was raped by a woman as a child and he has trauma because
of it.
Isn't that because he was pretending to have Well, that's what
he says.
>> That's what he says. >> And here I am thinking,
man, I'm being such a great guy, you know? I'm being such a great
guy because I'm making sure that this woman knows that they're
appreciated. I was just a The internet had brainwashed me into
being a And that that's just the truth. And there are so many
people who are like this. Like I remember I used to feel bad
while I'm paying for all the bills, hiring maids to clean, hiring
chefs to cook
while my partner does. >> Dude, he put some put some spice
ON THAT
>> nothing while I'm paying for everything.
>> He can't be talking about Free here, right? I think
Free managed a lot of his stuff. I think there's no way he's
talking about Free here if I'm not mistaken because I'm I'm pretty
confident Fe did a bunch of stuff like like in terms of management.
I I thought she made money and I think he must be talking about
Pinky. Well, he said 6 years ago.
Well, manage. Hold on. Manage is a legitimate thing. I don't
know if you know the the thing I hate most about like streaming
is just having to do like a bunch of the backend stuff that you
don't want to do. Like literally just reaching out to people,
making like uh plans to collab with people, like hammering that
out. that takes a long time. I don't like doing that. I like
showing up. I like going live. I like covering stuff I want to
cover. But maybe sometimes there's stuff that I should be aware
of that I I'm not getting told about. I think there's like a
whole other part to streaming that you could have help with and
you can like really succeed in a way that you don't by yourself.
And I'm pretty sure Teone is he said that she managed a bunch
of stuff. Like if she was managing his sponsorships and that
would make a big difference, although I don't know. while this
person displays TFT and does [__] nothing helping
me at all and then I would still feel bad asking for a [__]
cup of water. I mean, Jesus.
Holy [__] What co did to my mental was make me a
[__] [__] Jesus.
Oh my god. I even used to buy into that transgender, too. That
was ridiculous.
Holy. Thankfully, I'm breaking free from these shackles and undoing
the torment that all of the co did to me. But we got to a point
where somewhere white women, liberal women, far-left women have
gotten underneath the impression where if your husband asks you
to do anything, if your husband asks you to be loyal to them,
if your husband isn't
>> paying for everything, if your husband
>> Wait, I Where are these women? >> Isn't doing
everything in the world for you, they're abusing you. They're
raping you. And that's that's literally how
>> Just to be clear, Poke uh Pinky Chu did not say you
were raping her because you were paying for everything. She said
it because you were you forcibly like
penetrated her face. Okay, that's that's why she said that's
that's her story. It's nothing to do with like, oh, you paid
for everything or you you maybe didn't consider feel it's not
like that.
what the thing the there are these these women who think just
because they're a woman right once I'm not saying all women right
I'm just saying there are some women and you probably know them
where they think they're the prize by merely just existing
and this whole trend has been perpetuated by Twitter go to Twitter
right now and I want you to type in the the phrase girl failure
look it up look up girl failure Now, I I want to show you what
won't pull up any results. Uh the term boy failure. And let me
tell you why that >> Okay, dude. He's he watched the Pokemon
video and like totally spiraled off into some random incel he's
been following on Twitter. The topic is totally shifted. He immediately
he he like went, "Okay, Pokemon sucks." Also, something with
my ex. He clearly hints at his lawsuits or something. And then
it's like totally spiraling into look up these hashtags on Twitter.
Look up these hashtags on Twitter. these intel hashtags.
He like his his mental is so weak. He can't stay going in one
direction. He just immediately enters like this trauma spiral,
right? Where he is he's like, "Women have ruined my life. Women
have ruined my life every single time." >> Girl failures.
Girl failures are people who think they deserve love and praise
just because they're a woman while they have no accomplishments
whatsoever. men, boys, young men. They are trying to get you
to think that you need to be on your hands and knees every day
serving these people just because they're women. Holy. The the
idea of a 5050 working relationship is now considered abuse in
the big 2025. Oh my
>> I don't what?
I don't think so. Although I do expect that there will be some
rebound back to like, oh, I want a guy to take care of me like
as the economy goes down. I think that's true. But
but uh I don't know, dude. Who's doing this? Who's saying that
this is abuse? Like seriously, who's saying this is abuse in
any serious way? Come on, man. Come on,
Where where is that happening? I guess we could look up this
girl failure hashtag where apparently women are failures and
that's good. People are like, "Oh, it's really good that you
Hold on. #girl
failure. I have to make sure nothing pops up. Give me a second.
Yeah, first picture. Picture Bush from the Virgin community.
Yeah, I'm good. I'm never I'm not looking this up. This guy's
a sick [__] Okay, from
I I'm not even joking. That's what came up when I searched it.
Weirdo. Techone. My god. You asked >> I'm not falling for
that and looking it up on stream. You're not getting me out of
the game that easy. >> For your partner to pay for half
the bill. Oh my god. You asked for your partner to clean the
dishes. Oh my god. You You [__] asked your [__]
wife to vacuum the floor. Holy [__] You might as
well be beating them with the battle axe. I mean, this [__]
is crazy. It is.
There are so many young men who are being brainwashed and manipulated
to being their wife's
slave to where if you don't do everything they ask and expect
nothing in return, you're an abusive person. And guys,
>> again,
um he was accused of actual abuses by these people. That's what
he was accused of. I don't I don't know what he's talking about.
He was never accused because he didn't want to pay for a meal
because he asked his wife to clean the dishes. It was not like,
"Oh, I asked her to clean the dishes, so I'm like actually abusing
them." No.
Although, I will say I think there were some concerns that he
might have been sort of abusive to Pinky Chu because of her lack
of cleaning. I think
>> I I know I know. >> #belie all women. Where's
the belief? I didn't say he these women. I said that's their
accusation. They're not saying, "Oh, you were abusive because
you didn't do this." They're saying, "You were abusive because
you were coercive or you you literally ignored consent in these
situations. He's just lying about what their their complaint
was. I'm not saying it's true. I don't have to say it's true.
I can just wait, right? I can just wait and see what what evidence
comes out. If there's any evidence that comes out, >> we've
all seen this.
Now, I'm going to tell you some things that I've learned over
my 31 years of being an adult. Um, and I feel like I have a lot
more life experience than the majority of streamers. I feel like
the majority of streamers life experience is they were 16, they
played video games their entire life, they got lucky, blew up
on the internet, and that's pretty much their whole life. They
stay at home and play video games all day or they had their entire
career handed them by one of their parents. Um, now I'll be real.
If you've been following me for a while, uh, you realize that
I have worked for everything I've ever gotten. I never got any
break. The big breaks that I supposed to get actually caused
me a lot more turmoil than success. And
>> dude, what is he talking about? OTK right now. The thing
that like blew his career up.
>> And yeah, I >> got him all of the connections
that made him a big streamer. >> I'm going to be real.
I don't owe anybody for anything. And that's the bottom line.
Uh yeah, I worked my ass off of this as well as man, my life
was >> Bro, Miskf literally gave you the money to buy a
house.
Okay. He earned the right to joke about how you're weirdo lollycon
freak. All right. He gave you like 300 grand so you could buy
a house. He gets to he gets to mock your weird
I'm going to tell you guys some that you need to hear.
The number one thing where
you can tell if the woman or man is right for you is very simple.
It's not how much money they make. It's not how they look. It's
not about how good they can suck. It's not how good they can
eat ass. Those are great bonuses. Those are great bonuses.
The number one thing
this guy's been in one,
two committed relationships or something,
right? That's I think two. He had like framed him for years and
years and years and now he's going to say he he got married fairly
young and he's just going to tell us guys this is how you know
a relationship's correct. This is crazy. This is like um this
is like the 18-year-old Tik Tok girls who are like here's my
explanation of how to be happy in your marriage, right? They
get like married at 18 and they start turning out Tik Toks on
how to be happy in your marriage. Why would I believe you? You
don't have any experience. You don't have any successful experience.
Why Why am I supposed to believe you? you you don't have any
you have no reason I should believe you.
Get out of here. >> And this is the truth. The number one
thing
is if when you look at them, you
"I'm proud that they're my partner."
Being proud
of your partner
is so incredibly important. And I myself, I I haven't really
had too much relationship experience. Um, you know, I mean, I
I even had a relationship out of an obligation just to get a
green card before. Uh, that went on for much longer than I should
have let it go on for.
I have never really felt proud of my partner until today. And
I
>> Okay. What >> I will say it is such a euphoric
feeling not being embar.
>> Is that new lore? You did a green card marriage. I have
no idea if it's new lore. It might be like if he's talking about
Frame or something maybe >> to show them to, you know,
your relatives to your friends and when you're out in public,
you're happy. >> I don't think I don't think Frame was
a green card marriage, though. So, it would have had to be before
that.
Frame is a Frame was like his actual partner. He was literally
complaining about her. That can't be the green card marriage.
There's no way. >> Because I cannot tell you how humiliating
it is to have a partner where they're just
and
you got together with somebody cuz you're bored and then all
of a sudden you don't really know how to get out of this relationship
and you realize, oh, this person sucks. Um, yeah, you should
just have one simple thing that you
>> dude. Isn't that's a totally insane thing to just admit
when you're trying to give people relationship advice. Yeah,
I kind of just got like married cuz I was bored and then it didn't
work. Yeah, no. No [__]
No. I Why? Again, I don't know why this qualifies you to make
these kinds of videos talking about how you find a part. Find
somebody you're proud of.
it could be a little more complex than that. You could be very
proud of somebody who's a bad person. Somebody could do really
great things. You could be proud of the great things they do.
They could be a really bad person in your personal relationship.
There's maybe other things you got to consider. I don't know.
>> And is are you proud to call them your partner?
This will really open your eyes. When you go around your friends,
do you want to bring them? When you go to talk to your family,
do you want to talk about them? When they're standing by your
side, are you are you happy to be standing by them? And
it seems so obvious to to some of you
to some of you that that concept might seem so obvious,
but to a lot of you it's not. And I know it's not. And a lot
of you might be having a realization of, "Oh, no. I don't feel
that way at all." And I I really want,
>> SORRY. I need to clarify something. That was not me
yelling at Frame. Okay, I need I need I was not yelling at Frame.
I Frame, can you please come here real quick, dude? That was
not me yelling at Frame. That was Crobus biting Bean and Bean
was screaming. So I had to tell back up. Frame, can you confirm
that I was not yelling at you? >> He was not yelling at
me. >> Good, beautiful day. That's when my wife liked me.
>> I want you to think why that is.
Now it's getting harder. >> I'm not gonna let it hang.
What the You want me to do propaganda on my stream? I was gonna
watch the whole thing from the beginning, Chris. Thank you. to
be proud of who you are in a relationship with due to the content
that your female specifically female companions are. >> Painted
nails. Yeah, he was really brainwashed. Okay. He was really brainwashed.
He's now the guy who can educate you in degeneracy. Okay. He
was the most degenerate. He is the perfect guide. Listen, if
Tetto was telling me how he got out of the goon spiral that he
was in where he was making everything, he was like drawing depictions
of kids. He was everything around him. If he wants to do content
on how to escape the goon spiral, more power to you, buddy, okay?
But you need to have humility when you do that. You don't get
to talk and and throw judgment at other people because you were
there. That's like a heroin addict, right? when he throws judgment
at other people for either being narcissists or being gooners
or whatever. The that's like a heroin addict going to like the
uh the methodone clinic and judging the people there, brother.
That was you. You should have empathy for these people. Do not
do not sit here and tell me about how you how you like get relationships.
I don't give a [__] about that. That's stupid. Tell
people how to get away from Yeah. Off to drawn depictions of
13-year-old girls. That's that's what you can give expert expert
opinion on. That's how you can get people help >> uh digesting.
Now, I'm not going to lie that incel content for men is now higher
than ever. Um, which I consume quite a lot of and I think it's
hilarious to be honest, but I don't take it.
>> Okay. Sometimes techone does surprise
That's a crazy admission
to intel content is at its height and I consume all of it. I
am the biggest consumer of intel. I love being told how women
are. All right, I can't get enough. I can't get enough of how
women >> seriously. But there are some people who think
that women are like dogs. They don't deserve respect. And why
the would I waste my time with any of these women when I can
just be gay and have sex with my homies? When in reality, women
are great. Men are great, but it's when they have a perfect working
relationship is when it works the best. Now, when is that?
I'm a very old-fashioned type of guy. I believe in a traditional
type of relationship because it's worked for hundreds of thousands
of years and it will continue to work for hundreds of thousands
of years. However, with more rise of women being told, uh, if
you have a kid, your life is completely over. First of all, shut
the up. Having a child with someone you love and finding someone
to marry, someone that you love and you're proud of is the most
beautiful thing that you can do in this entire human existence
that we live. There's a lot of women saying, "Oh, I
>> why? Hold on. How is that commensurate with having the
worst opinion of women that you could possibly imagine?" Tech
a
the Tequila Sunset tweets are good around this. Just the old
clips is the feet in the mouth thing because Teone himself has
a history of liking lollycons. talking about characters that
went as low as 6 to 8 years old while ranking them in a waifu
tier list. >> Next up, Palon. Dude, I feel like if Palon
were to visit me, I feel like we'd just be best friends,
you know? And I bet she would taste delicious.
Imagine how Pon's feet would taste when she's 18. Like cinnamon
and honey. Uh, should be >> I'm sorry. It really does require
playing like every single time. Unfortunately, I don't want to
have to play that for you, okay? I don't want to have to do that
to you, but it it is >> for I can't believe she's not butterful.
Chi-Chi S tier. Adorable. Okay. Hilarious. Cute. Get this girl
a cocoa goat. Okay. She is adorable. She is beautiful. Dude,
this girl is already running a hotel at like age six. In patch
2.0, You know, when we gather the Dragon Balls and we revive
Chi-Chi and then she gets to expand to level 18 and age 18, imagine
how amazing she would >> Because tech
guy does a lot of uh creative writing about children being adults
for some reason. I imagine how awesome it would be if this girl
was 18. Imagine imagine how how awesome this would be. Imagine
how cool it would be if if she were an adult.
I It's It's like not even really coded. It's just right out there
in the open. >> Jesus, stop me if you know what I'm talking
about. 34, 35, 32 year old women saying, "I want to play video
games for the rest of my life." Oh my god, what a sad, miserable
experience you have. And then you have people like, "Oh, dude,
what are you doing, man?" Like, why are you hating on these people?
Cuz they're wasting their life. Are you telling me that I'm a
bad guy because I tell an alcoholic to stop drinking? I'm sorry
it's not what they want to hear, but unfortunately it's what's
best for them. And while all these people waste their life, waste
their eggs inside their body having fun and play. Dude, how why
do we keep going back to the eggs,
bro? This is not This is not the grocery store. Okay,
we inflation must not be high enough. These guys can buy as many
any as many egg cartons as they want to make all of these jokes.
It's nuts. playing video games and being a [__] random
men.
They're wasting time where they could be finding that one true
person to spend the rest of their life with and have a happy,
beautiful family with.
I'm sorry. I'm I'm not the bad guy for letting these people know.
Congratulations. You're wasting your life. Straight up. And you're
not going to make me feel like I'm a bad guy. And I don't care
how many Only Fans tell me, uh, well, let them do what they want.
Okay, great. Yes. Enjoy all the marijuana methamphetamines. Now,
>> hold on. But the I dude, I don't even have a problem
with the I don't have a problem with the Only F. You want to
critique Only Fans or people not taking seriously or the [__]
Go off and critique it. But like
I lots of these criticisms don't apply to Pokemon. Who is the
subject of the video? You've just you've gone down the same whatever
him and Tactical Templar are on the same train, okay? Going to
the same place, watching the same content, getting radicalized
the same way. It's It's wild, right? Like I But you're so transparently
projecting your criticisms or or the traits of the Only Fans
women you dislike onto Pokemon for no reason other than she's
a woman.
>> Oh, guys, I'm just going to say what nobody else will.
Pokemon only got big because of her fat ass. What? >> Have
fun. >> Like, I thought Pokémon was literally the example
of she didn't do content at all. She was like a unicorn on Twitch
for a while cuz she was she was famous. She was a big streamer,
but she didn't do content. She didn't even make that she didn't
remotely make that a part of her platform. I thought that's what
she was known for forever.
Oh yes, now I'm the good guy because I'm an enabler. Jesus Christ.
I I really hate how we live in this world where people think,
and I've talked about this so much before, people think you're
a good guy if you tell people what they want to hear. I'm sorry.
The good people are going to be the ones who tell you what you
need to hear. And that's the bottom,
>> dude. What?
hold on. 7 hours ago for Techone. When was the Tactical Templar
video? There's no way that they actually did videos at the same
time, is there? Hold on. Poke poke man.
Oh, it's not this one, though. Hold on. Let me go grab the Tactical
Templar video again. One second. One second. One second. Oh,
do I not have Oh, I don't have it here. Hold on. Hold on. Let
me grab it.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Hold on. Seven. They released
at the same
There's no way. There's no way that's not fully true. JTO, she
didn't do like hot tub streams and [__] like that.
Okay. Where was she being like super then? Are there clips of
her being like she did thousands of hours of content? I would
assume there's like a library of her like bending over doing
a whole bunch of Right.
>> Line. Enjoy wasting your [__] life, but
I promise you when you're 15 >> Oh, sorry. Sorry. All right.
So, I want to go back because they're saying the exact same things.
Where where are these talking points coming from? Okay. Where
are they coming? I want to know. >> People think, and I've
talked about this so much before, people think you're a good
guy if you tell people what they want to hear. I'm sorry. The
good people are going to be the ones who tell you what you [__]
need to hear.
>> This is okay. That's fine. what you need to hear,
but you're you're literally you're just transparently taking
criticisms of different kinds of women and applying them to Pokémon
now in the same video.
Like even if you accepted this premise that like, oh, um, I have
to actually tell this woman because nobody else will. What's
what,
how is this supposed to help? You're not trying to help her.
And the idea that you're like pretending you are giving friendly
or or friendly advice or advice you expect her to take, that's
preposterous. It's all just insult. Yeah, that's not what I'm
saying. Scuba Fiend, but you're too understand what I'm saying.
It's fine. >> And that's the bottom line. Enjoy wasting
your life. >> Isn't it just generic manosphere? Yes, but
here's the thing. It's generic manosphere for like Only Fans
girls that they're applying to somebody who's not an Only Fans
girl. And I'm wondering if there's someone else doing it that
they're both drawing from because it just seems very goofy to
me. And again, I want to point out I I can almost guarantee Asmin
Gold doesn't bite the the bullet on this one. He doesn't take
the bait. I don't think so. I think Asmin Gold knows. I think
as gold this will be one of those situations where he steers
out of the [__] whirlpool that these all go into.
>> But I promise you when you're 50 and you realize all
that did was your liver and leave you with 50,000 burn bridged
with men you never cared about, you'll think, hm, damn, maybe
I shouldn't have played so much Valerant. There's so many streamers
that I just have pity for because they think they're happy, they
think they're successful because their numbers are going up and
they're playing all these games, but when all of that fades,
they'll realize what they've built up. And all that is a massive
pile of money that will be useful for nothing when they can't
find a single partner because they're so self-obsessed. Nobody
wants to deal with them besides their skits who are probably
going to kill them in their sleep. Uh,
sorry guys. You know, I I really actually know I really enjoy
being that guy, but that's the truth. There's there's so much
poison in the women's
>> Yeah, Hookie Man is totally brain poisoned. It's all
women. All women are are obviously being mind controlled.
Just wait. Tone Tone's so close. Okay, Tone is so close. Just
wait until he starts talking about who's doing the mind controlling.
Wait, TeeOne,
why? Who's doing the mind control and why are they doing it?
Techone, why who's doing the mind control and why are they doing
it? There's only one stop at the end of this train track uh these
train tracks. Okay. And it's uh it's at Awitz. All right. Who's
He's going to learn. He's going to start learning. Okay. >> All
right. You can have your border wall. Just vote for us one more
time and then we'll build it. I promise.
And then they get in and then they go, "Excuse me, boy.
>> You voted for the wall. How about gay
>> boy?" Bae. All right. All right. >> Okay. Hold
on. No. Stop. Stop. Don't play it again. Don't play it again.
Don't play it again. One time's enough. One time's enough.
Techone's right there. He's right there. You know, he's already
watching a Fentes content. He's just like, he's right there.
He's about to start doing collabs and [__] I promise
it's right. I feel it. It's there. All the signs are there. >> Yeah.
You know, having kids is bad. You know, having having a guy who
wants to take care of you and let you know what the right thing
to do is bad. Like, oh my god. The idea of listening to a man
is like the equivalent of them putting a shotgun in their mouth.
Like, it's really that bad. Like for real, is it really so bad
to find a guy who will devote himself to you and make sure that
he will protect you and and and I'm sorry. There's >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I thought you were a [__]
for doing this. For devoting yourself to a woman. I thought you
were a [__] for doing this. Which one is it? Are
you supposed to devote yourself or not? You're just complaining
but 10 minutes ago in the same video about how you devoted yourself
to this woman. You're a total [__]
Are you talking about just sex? Oh, monogamy is that that's the
bar for relationships apparently. Monogamy. That's all TTO has
to do in a relationship. Monogamy. As long as he doesn't [__]
anybody else, it's fine. >> A lot of women who do need
protecting. They do. It's a dangerous world. It is. We already
see what happens on the buses and subways. It's bad. Okay.
It is.
But the idea that having a man who loves you and respects you,
>> we got to speed it up. Okay. We got to speed it up.
I can't do a lot more techy content right now. >> It's
like >> I've got I went I went while he was ranting. Okay,
I wasn't paying that much attention. While he was ranting, I
went and found the Asmin Gold time stamp.
>> I I have faith. All right, in Asmin Gold, the brother
Asmin Gold, I believe he can get through this without making
an app of himself. I believe I believe it can happen. I want
to say it can happen. I believe it can happen. >> Really
going to act like that's terrible. And and and and fellas, I
do want to let you know, you should also respect your wife. You
should also respect your, you know, your partner. Obvious, I
feel gay calling it a partner. Jesus Christ. Your wife. You should.
A relationship is about balance. A relationship is about being
able to respect each other. Just like a woman should be able
to obey her husband. A husband should also be able to obey the
wife and make sure that it is a good, healthy, functioning relationship.
Have your roles. Personally, I prefer the roles of me being a
caretaker and my partner being taking care of the home and the
kids and the pets. I think that's great. However, you can do
whatever the [__] you want. That's just the type
of man that I like to be. I like being a provider. I like being
a worker. I like being a protector. I like being a nurturer.
Um, yeah, I think it's great. Obviously, every relationship is
different. That's just one that I enjoy. But ladies, it's okay
to
>> He literally he literally talked about how those those
roles, the nurturer one, made him look like a [__]
before. >> Be a housewife. I know there's a lot and I get
this message a lot actually. I mean this genuinely and I can
post a compilation of this on Twitter, but how many women reach
out to me and they say, "Thank you for praising the house lifestyle."
There are so many women who have been brainwashed to think that
just >> the house lifestyle, the house lifestyle, housewife
lifestyle, >> a good obedient wife, taking care of the
house, taking care of the kids, and taking care of the husband
is some like, "Oh my god, you're such a slave." No, it's a beautiful
thing. It is one of the most useful things that any man can have
is let your man go out into the wild, bring home the food, bring
home the supplies, bring home the bread while your wife is out
there taking care of the house, big smiles, hugs, kisses, passionate,
and you know, making sure everything runs smooth at home. It's
a great life. It really is. It's a perfect balance. And I I feel
so horrible for the rise of the girl bosses who are going to
realize that the biggest mistake they're making is just >> Hey,
it's the unfortunate thing here is this is also just totally
disconnected from
any reality for most people, right? Nobody nobody will point
this out. Hey, um is anybody who watches Teeone, anybody who
donates to Techone, are they making enough money to have a single
family or a single
uh home with a single income
and kids? Is anyone who's making that much money? It's like streamers
and late like uh like engineers and doctors. It's like that's
it. It's like nobody nobody else is doing that. Nobody who watches
Techone, who's into gotcha games is making enough money that
they can have a wife who stays home and does stuff and nothing
else. Everybody else has to deal with the the actual reality
of needing a dual income to make ends meet, to be able to buy
a house, to be able to build a life together. So you're you're you're
describing a problem. Oh, I I like taking care of people. Oh,
why aren't there any like housewives? Cuz they have to work in
every other relationship, bro. >> Just villainizing anybody
love and take care of them. >> It's embarrassing. It is.
And I and I do think influencers like Pokémon and Co are largely
to blame for a lot of this rise and that mentality of we don't
need no man. And the worst part is, do you want to know why so
many of these content creators are in the scenario where they
say, "You don't need any man. I don't need no man." It's because
they all have a man. It's because they're all in relationships
and they understand that if they were to go public with that
relationship, all of their sensible
and if you want to disagree with me, you can. But you're wrong.
Every single one of these people is in a relationship. They are,
guys. >> Okay, it's actually starting to get really really
redundant with Techone. I I tried for a little bit. I'm going
to switch to the Asmin Gold thing. I feel like Asmin Gold's going
to be on my side, but we'll see. How long did he was he on it
for? The longer he does this segment for, >> this is what
I was, >> the less likely, the less likely it is to work.
Okay. The less likely he is to be like
>> Oh, he only does what, 15 minutes. No, he's on my side.
He's absolutely on my >> So, um, I don't really know how
to title this other than just reading the title. Uh, Pokemon
shows off engagement ring that she bought herself. >> Oh,
that would be really funny, Kerski. That would actually be really
funny. >> Okay. All right. Here we go. Let's see it. I
bought an engagement ring for myself. Okay, but you guys told
me to. In the comments my last video, you guys kept talking about
a ring. A lot of you were saying, "Girl, just go get one for
yourself."
So, that's what I did. A ring at Vulgate that I just fell in
love with. It felt like way too much to get for myself. But then
the more I thought about it, I was like, I hope someday I actually
get engaged. The person >> This is, you know what's really
kind of Okay, I I have faith. Okay, his facial expressions don't
provide faith, but I have faith. Okay,
Asmin as God cannot fail. He cannot fail me now. Okay, I'm betting
I'm betting on Asmin Gold having the correct take here. I'm betting
the farm. I >> I wouldn't say funny. I don't think it's
really appropriate here. I feel like this video is just kind
of sad. I'm going to be honest. I think this is kind of like
a sad video. It is
>> that you are engaged to the most in your >> Hold
on. Hold on. It's still way better, but I think I think he's
going to get >> lifetime is your damn self. >> So
why shouldn't I get this ring for my damn self? So this is me
proposing to >> Oh my god.
>> It's like there's like a certain level of like poetic
continuity with the universe that the >> Oh, no. No. Please
don't say that. She'll never get married. >> She got looks
like a snake.
Never mind. That's just funny. >> It is like this is like
a >> Hold on. He's taking it a different direction. Hold
on. He's taking it a different direction.
No, no, no, no, no. He's not going down the incel pipeline. He's
going this this is a snake behind the scenes. >> Poetic
thing. Like this is the kind of stuff that makes me feel like
I'm living in a simulation. >> That's your indication.
>> Uh the gorgeous diamonds. Even the packaging is beautiful.
The way that it contrasts, you know, when is so pretty. Like
honestly, if you were to in a lab figure out, okay, you have
an attractive woman who's like semi famous or very famous already.
How could she drive engagement on a new platform? She wants to
go to Tik Tok. She wants to make Tik Toks. How could she drive
engagement? Okay, I can show you a million random no talent losers
who are huge on Tik Tok because they just generate rage bait
all the time. >> What's up, Ruben Rub? >> I asked
myself to marry me. I declined. >> That's unfortunate.
Okay. Um, being a what is it? What do they call? Oh, the people
with what? What is is it did disassociative
identity disorder?
Those people with multiple identities, whatever they call themselves.
Okay. Like asking yourself to marry yourself.
Unlucky. Not a lot of Not a lot of commitment-minded people in
my what's the group called? Hivemind. No.
Pod. No. There's a word for it. Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter.
We continue with >> You want to eat it? Is that just me?
Like it's so
Yes. Not a lot of uh long-term commitment people in the system.
>> Delectable. Will I be with me for the rest of my life?
Well, yes. I have no choice. But yes, I'm going to have the >> She
could develop a personality disorder >> opportunity to
gift my husband the sickest engagement ring for men that there
ever was. And I cannot wait. You guys know how much I love gift
giving. And just that idea makes me so happy. >> This is
such a sad video. I'm gonna be honest. It really >> Oh,
he he bit the he took the bait. >> Really is. It's such
a sad >> Sorry. I was saying though, like there are so
many people who get big on Tik Tok because you generate rage
bait and Tik Tok promotes stuff that it gets engagement, right?
This is so easy. She's like so good at this content, I'm telling
you. And she is totally like
curated in everything she presents as an influencer. Do you think
Do you think Pokemon man just decides to go and she's like, "Oh,
I'm just going to do this." And it has no intention. There's
nothing no thought behind it. No idea of how it'll be received.
Cope. Cope. Cope. Dude, cope.
I'm I know I'm correct on this. I'll stand against the world.
Okay. I'll plant both feet in the ground and say this is like
absolutely
curated, manufactured, manicured rage bait. Okay, it totally
intentional, totally obvious. If you can't see that, you're not
going to make it. You're being filtered. Okay, you're just being
>> Bad video.
>> Yeah, Pokemon is the smartest person ever. Luckily,
she'd just have to be about 100 times smarter than you. Okay,
about 100 IQ or so. Anybody with an average IQ can just understand
exactly how to do this. There are literally websites that tell
you how to do this stuff. It's very easy to understand. >> I
mean I mean some guy needs to like marry her or something, right?
I mean something's got to happen. I mean I it this is just sad.
It is. It's just so sad. It's worse than dating AI. Yeah. I I
don't know what this is. That a wedding band. Yeah.
I don't know, man. And she's starting to sound like a crazy catwait.
No. No. I mean, she hasn't fully evolved into that yet, right?
I mean, we'll see what happens. And uh yeah, I don't know, guys.
Um
she won't marry a guy. I don't know. Do you have no thanks? I
don't know about that. I just uh it's pure nar. >> No thanks.
Listen, she's she sounds like a [__] I would I wouldn't
get married to her. She sounds like a >> sounds like a
total [__] Noism. No >> Well, I don't know.
Like I see something like this and she's like 29 and you know,
like it's just kind of I don't know. It it's I mean there's part
of me that like wants to like meme on her for it, but there's
also another big part of me that's like, well, this is kind of
like this is kind of depressing, right? It's a little Oh, I keep
thinking he can pick it up. Okay.
Oh, I had I had faith that Asiggo could do it, that he was the
one in this bubble that could figure it out, but the audience
capture is too powerful. Okay. Is far too powerful. One second.
I'll be right back. I'm just let you listen to him for two seconds.
>> Depressing. So yeah, I mean I don't know what to say.
Who needs God more, Pokemon or Caseyron?
I think Caseyron by mile. So yeah, Boane's a little bit conceited
and like kind of sanctimonious and patronizing, but Case is awful.
Terrible. Terrible. The worst. So yes. And uh bro, that's exactly
that's exactly the way that I feel. Godamn. This is the most
pathetic I've ever seen. Ring with no
Bro, what's there? Oh my god, John is
he just lets him know, man. He says some of the wildest.
And uh yeah, there it is. It's going up. Oh my god. And uh Oh,
Hogwarts can't conjure up a spell to save him. Yeah, I guess
this is as pathetic as Anita. This is another like uh Gamergate
Pro gamer anti game. I can't remember. Zirka ring with no Speaking
of Zirka, I think we have Zirka content coming up. Apparently
Sneo and Zurka had a big fight. >> It's not right. And
>> this this person is like one of the worst Twitter accounts.
Okay. This This is Speaking of This Recognizes Pokemon's game.
Okay. They just do rage bait from the other angle. >> No,
it's pathetic. Yeah, I guess so. And uh Wow. Marrying her. Oh,
there's this other girl. I did not get married, but I did have
a wedding themed birthday in Stockholm this summer. It was silly
and fun. We had a bachelor party, rehearsal dinner, and ceremony.
Okay, that hold on. That is sad. This is sad. Okay,
this is sad.
That's way different. That's way way way different from what
happened with Pokémon. Okay, this one is actually sad. I'm I'm
sorry. That one is weird,
>> right? You You look at, okay, how much money does this
person make? What are they doing to like like how much are they
putting themselves out to do this? This would have cost money.
This would have actually been like a what do you call like a
I don't know like a significant drain on her resources on on
the amount of money she has and everything, right? Pokemon is
sitting there like, "Oh, I could do whatever I want. I'm going
to pimp these people off today." This is like not This is somebody
who like wanted to experience a wedding. This [__]
up. It's really [__] up. Okay. Nope. Nope. Not good.
It cost Poke money. Yeah, but Pokey has Sorry. You understand
that spending 5% of your yearly income on something as a meme
is way different than spending 0.01% of your income on a meme,
right? That those are different things
We we all get it. We all understand. I think it's very obvious,
right? That Pokemon it costs nothing. You don't know that. Oh,
if Anita Sarkeesian is actually like a billionaire or something.
If she's making like a money and she threw a fed wedding cuz
she could do whatever the [__] she wants. Maybe
that lady could be rich. I doubt it. We know a lot about that
lady. Do you not know about that lady? Yeah, I'm saying she ran
out of her DEI program money. Yes, exactly. She just wanted that
ring and made a rage bait video to make money off of it. I don't
know if that's true, but
you don't know who Anita Sarkeesian is. I I'm pretty sure we
know she is not rich. But dude, the Pokemon situation got everywhere.
It's